hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar establishing a robust 37 marker
math cytometry
assay for deep single-cell immunes
profiling of whole blood i am michelle
ashton of lab herbs and I'll be your
moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab roots and brought to you by Milton E
biotech to learn more about our sponsor
please visit www.gfi.com/webmonitor time
you want during the presentation to do
so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send will answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation click on the support tab
found at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the ask question
box located on the far + of your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits I now
present today's speakers Mona almari PhD
product manager of flow cytometry at
milks new biotech and a deep Raman PhD
the director of technology development
of the human immune monitoring center at
Icahn School of Medicine at Mount Sinai
New York for a complete biography on our
speakers please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen Mona and Adeeb
will now begin their presentations
so thank you for
introduction Michelle and thank you all
for joining this webinar I will give you
a brief background about what master
geometry is exactly and then I will talk
about the advantages of this method in
the next point I will tell you more
about our of the chef portfolio then I
will introduce the technology of
recombinant antibodies and advantages
for method Rama tree and in the end I
will show you X and Larry customer data
I guess most of you are listening are
familiar with method from a tree so I
will keep it short here in message on
the tree cells are labeled with heavy
metal conjugated antibodies similar to
flow cytometry feds are then nebulized
into droplets and then they are
vaporized atomized and ionized this ion
cloud that you can see between C and D
is then filtered to enrich the heavy
metal ions before they are quantified by
time-of-flight mass spectrometry the
mass of the metals will then identify
the expression of specific markers
because the cells are labeled similarly
to flow cytometry this technique is
basically a fusion between flow
cytometry and mass spectrometry
when comparing both methods with the
Java flow cytometry is very fast the
cells are not destroyed which also
allows for downstream experiments and
sorting and the handling is not as
advanced as Master tamo tree advantages
of method Roma tree on the other hand
are that you have almost no spectral
overlap there for you therefore you
don't have to compensate and the Penner
design is much easier another point is
that you don't have cellular
autofluorescence because heavy methods
do not occur in living cells the results
are on a single cell level and at the
same time allow for multi parameter
analysis because up to 40 parameters can
be measured in one run and basically the
same antibodies as the flow can be used
and because most of the antibodies
available for mating biotech were
developed especially for flow cytometry
our antibodies are also suitable for
Master tamo tree experiments and this is
why we are actually providing pure
antibodies from a sitamma tree right now
we have around about 130 antibodies in
the correct format available some of
them are traditional monoclonal
antibodies derived from hybridoma clones
and some are recombinant antibodies but
we are more and more switching to
recombinant antibodies which I will
explain later on they are provided in
the format of 100 micrograms in 100
microliters NM PBS only without any
additives because this format is
necessary for the commercially available
communication kit because any additives
could interfere with the communication
process if you would like to purchase a
clone not available in the master drama
tree suitable format you can easily
request this antibody via our custom
antibody design service when entering
our web page since we have almost 1000
different recombinant clones available
plus of course additional hybridoma
drones and the recombinant clones all
have RIA and the clone name so that you
can identify them easily
now in the next part I will explain more
in detail why it make sense to switch
from polyclonal or monoclonal antibodies
to recombinant antibodies and in the
past years there is a growing concern in
the scientific community that many
published results are not repute
reproducible by other researchers as
reflect reflected by multiple
publications and articles antibodies are
considered as one of the key variable in
the system that actually a reproducible
results in 2015
various articles were published in
Nature highlighting the importance of
antibody validation and they also call
for a new generation of antibodies which
are the recombinant antibodies that are
defined by the DNA sequence in 2018 even
more papers came out demonstrating that
hybridoma derived monoclonal antibodies
are also not very specific and that
recombinant antibodies are the way the
other way we should go I will quickly
explain you with the route the reasons
for this and hybridoma clones so the
ones used for traditional monoclonal
antibodies are generated from a fusion
product of antibody producing b-cells
and immortal myeloma cells sometimes the
hybridoma generated anybody products
also contain the contaminating light
chains which are shown here in green
which are produced by the myeloma cells
in an ideal situation the same
antibodies also produced over a long
period of time and petrels however when
they are in culture over several
passages spontaneous mutations can lead
to genetic drifts and an antibody
product different from the expected
product will be the result in the end in
addition when hybrid or misaligned eyes
out then the antibody clone is
practically lost forever
Vangie bodies can also be contaminated
by the immunoglobulin coming from the
serum used for calibration which is
shown here in grey such contaminations
decrease the purity of the product and
furthermore the impurities can vary from
lot to lot making the hybridoma derived
product inconsistent we common Andrea
Finity anybodies on the other hand and
genetically engineered the defined DNA
is introduced into the mammalian cells
which are programmed to only Express the
product of
DNA sequence because they are not
derived from B cells and the cells are
cultivated in defined culture conditions
no contaminating light chains or
antibodies can be present and further
muscle cells are reproducible when they
sell cell line might die out due to all
these aspects larger consistency as well
as purity of the product is ensured and
because they are all genetically
engineered and they can also be altered
in a defined way so in this slide I will
show you the features of real Finity
recombinant antibodies and why this is
actually beneficial for method Raman
tree experiments they are recommend li
generated leading to lot enough
consistency and highly reproducible
results due to the expression in
standardized mammalian culture systems
no unwanted aji impurities secure
furthermore as I said before because
they are genetically engineered they can
be ordered in a different way therefore
we mutated the FC region so that no FC
blocking is necessary and background
signal is reduced they also have a human
igg1 backbone and because of this no
isotype dependent variation during metal
conjugation can occur and all of this is
not only theory because Melanie already
decided very early to count on
recombinant antibodies so our first real
finiti antibodies have been released in
2012
in 2015 the most common markers were
available already as recombinant
versions and now in 2019 we have the
largest portfolio of roughly 1000
recombinant clones that are optimized
for flow cytometry to also address the
reproducibility crisis even more we will
extend the communication on how we
validate our antibodies to you as a
customer and before I hand over to a
deep I will quickly show you some
customer data due to the high purity of
recombinant antibodies the comparison of
flow and mask cytometry data using the
same clone becomes highly reliable and
here's one example showing data from
Karl Johan my back he used the same
reason in T antibody for the same reason
ad clone for flow and mass photometry
and as you can see the results using two
different methods are very consistent
showing the same
population size another example from our
custom customer Amir Horowitz shows that
the separation of the positive and
negative population is nicely visible
below you can see a Tiffany plot and in
it is a glove as many of you might know
many parameters are taking into account
and therefore impurities coming from the
product might already mess up your
results I chose this example because it
is known that n kg - a and M kg - see a
mutually exclusively expressed and as
you can see the results shall not show
nicely the expected expression pattern
because one marker is only visible in
the in the left panel and the other one
is only positive in the right panel
as a summary slide I collected the key
characteristics again and most of the
antibodies for method drama tree are
recombinant Lea generated in a defined
expression system which of course leads
to a high alert alert consistency as
explained earlier they all have the same
isotype making metal communication very
consistent
they are validated for flow and are
therefore suitable for meso trauma tree
furthermore we offer more than 1000
recombinant clones which gives you a
high flexibility to choose their panels
and last but not least they have a
mutated FC region reducing the
background signal and with this I would
like to hand over to a deep Hoffman
thanks Mona following on Mona's
presentation I was going to go through
and show you an example of a specific
project in which we've been deploying
some of these Rihanna bodies for immune
monitoring purposes but before getting
into that I want to buy a little bit
context for where this work is being
done and and kind of how it falls into
our broader range of operations so the
human immune monitoring center at Mount
Sinai is a center that aims to combine a
range of technology platforms together
with computational technical and
scientific expertise and bring this to
bear on a range of patient cohorts to
derive biological insights particularly
in the setting of trials and one of the
challenges in doing this sort of work is
really being able to balance innovative
assay development with rigorous
standardization that's required to be
able to minimize kind of the
experimental and technical variability
that can often compromise data in this
sort of setting and so our our general
mode of operation is to is to acquire
blood or tissues from from patients and
then we do have a large arsenal of those
technologies as well as basic sample
collection processes that we can bring
to bear on these tissues with the goal
of ultimately generating a range of data
types that can hopefully help to inform
these mechanisms identify biomarkers and
potential by therapeutic targets and for
the purpose of today's discussion I'm
really only going to be focusing on math
cytometry our sights off which Moana
already introduced and we find a very
useful technique for performing these
sort of high dimensional single-cell
analyses and so the specific study I'm
going to be talking to you about today
is part of a broader study that's the
title
activate the goal of which is we
evaluate the effect of the vaginal
microbiome on the developing immune
response of infants and so the
hypothesis here is that exposure the
vaginal microbiome has an impact on the
development of Pediatrics food allergies
and so this is a clinical trial being
performed at Mount Sinai and there's
three arms of the trial there is one
cohort of conventional vaginal delivery
a second cohort of c-section deliveries
and a third cohort of c-section
deliveries who are seated with vaginal
microbiota
the infant's in each of these three arms
are being followed for for 12 months and
the the primary goal of the study is way
to evaluate the impact of this on the
incidence of food allergies but in
parallel we have sort of a second
research arm which is to also conduct a
longitudinal profiling of immune cells
during the 12 month period to be able to
see if we can you know a determine
correlates I mean call lots of these
different sort of delivery modes as well
as exposures a different microbial and
in addition to see if we can find me in
college of development of pediatric
allergy and so this kind of study has a
few specific sort of challenges
associated with it
one is that this is deal with neonatal
samples and so the amounts of blood that
we can collect any given time point are
quite small typically under a milliliter
they there's also a challenge it's a
fairly large study in scale so each of
those three arms has a pretty large
number of patients there are several
longitudinal time points and this
results in over 500 samples are going to
be collected and processed over the or
several years in addition the goal is
for this to be a multi-site study with
several clinics contributing samples and
and this presents additional
complications for having a streamlined
workflow that can't necessarily be
deployed easily at each of those
clinical sites
so what I'm going to talk to you about
today is sort of the process of how we
went about developing a workflow for the
purpose of the study and I'm going to
cover sort of many of the kind of key
best practices I think that are relevant
any sort of study of this kind of
magnitude starting with sort of the
target selection antibody selection how
we go about conjugating validating a
panel and then some considerations and
actually developing a streamlined
experiment but workflow to be able to
facilitate data analysis down the line
and one spoiler alert is that the study
is just getting underway so I'm really
talking about the development of the
methodologies of the study I'm not gonna
be telling you anything about the the
outcomes of this research study so sorry
to disappoint there alright so in
developing any sort of map cytometry
study clearly your insights at any of
these these sorts of projects are
largely driven by your antibody panel
that you develop and so developing an
effective anybody panel is one of the
kind of primary challenges and arts I
think of ultimately gaining useful
insights from a cytometry study and
generally the HMC we take sort of a
three three pronged approach to
developing an effective panel we have a
set of markers that are required to
comprehensively identify major cell
lineages we provide sort of a second
tier of markers that help to provide
deeper stratification of specific
lineages that are relevant in the
context of the given study and then
lastly we try and identify markers that
are potentially in a very dynamically in
the context of that study and in
developing this panel or in sort of
balancing these three arms across
multiple studies there's always this
challenge of being able to optimize
optimally customize a panel to gain you
know maximize your study specific
insights and being able to balance this
with the need to be able to standardize
at least a subset of markers to
facilitate cross study comparisons and
insight and doing this kind of at that
orange category at the top the markers
to comprehensively identify the major
lineages is one of the easiest to tackle
because there's kind of a fairly broad
range of literature supporting what
those should be the other two really do
require sort of more understanding of
the context of specific study and the
nuances in that context
and so for this particular study that
first set of markers is sort of a list
of about 13 antibodies that we sort of
use as our core set of markers that we
think is the the minimal number of
markers needed to identify most major
circulating immune cell subsets and with
this we can do a pretty good job of
deriving that get a broader heron a day
of the circulating immune system we
supplement this with an additional set
of markers to provide deeper
stratification the specific cell types
that we think are relevant for the
specific study for example things like
CD 25 and CD 21 27 to help us identify T
regs we have a few sort of allergy
focused markers there are things like SC
epsilon receptor and CR t h2 and then we
we also had a hypothesis around the
study involved in homing and so there's
a pretty big range of chemokine
receptors there which are also used some
context to help define polarized t-cell
subsets and then we have this primal set
of markers that we think also provide
some additional subsets stratification
but also expect our gonna potentially
very dynamically in the context of of
inflammatory immune responses
and so having going to put together this
list of potential targets that we think
are going to be informative in this
context the next step is identifying
antibodies against this target and
there's there sort of several
considerations in picking anybody's you
know obviously the specificity and the
sensitivity of individual clones is a
big one
and as mona has already described in her
section previously the recombinant
antibodies provide a range of advantages
that we want to take use of in the
context of the study in particular one
of the the points that Moe didn't touch
on which I think is relevant from a
cytometry is the fact that all these
antibodies have a constant FC region
presumably means that when you are
custom conjugating anybody's you can get
much more uniform conjugation of
different antibodies because you don't
have any sort of variation and the
available residues for conjugation in
that in that FC region and kind of prior
to start in this project we had already
generated some data showing that the
performance with the Rios was was at
least comparable if not better to our
experience of several other anybody's
targeting those same clothes and so we
went ahead and worked to develop a
largely RIA based panel for these
antibodies and I should note that when
we when we first start this project
which was I think a couple of years ago
the most severe antibodies were in fact
not available as off-the-shelf
antibodies from meltonian so this did
require I request a custom formulate
almost all of these to make them
compatible for math cytometry
essentially to have them in a stabilizer
free format since then however almost
all of these are available as catalog
anybodies which i think would would make
this an easier workflow for folks
looking to do this down the line
um and so the last component here then
is a we've got our we've got our target
selected we've got or anybody's the
Nexus actually conjugate these two
isotopes from a cytometry and there's
sort of two primary considerations that
we we take into consideration when
deciding what isotopes should be
assigned to watch anybody the first is
sort of the the relative transmission
efficiency on the instrument also known
as the mass response curve so mass
saitama ters do sort of have an optimal
detection range which is typically in
the range of about you know 152 to 172
or so as you can see from from this
publication from a couple of years ago
it is somewhat instrument specific but
what this means that is that if we
expect that particular antigens are
going to be present at relatively low
abundance to maximize detection of those
antigens we want to couple them to
isotopes that are optimally present in
this sort of high efficiency part of the
mass range whereas relatively high
abundance targets can be relegated to
sort of the the left and right side here
the upper and lower masses and where we
can still expect to see decent
resolution of those populations despite
the lower transmission efficiency a
second equally important aspect is the
consideration of signal interferences so
map cytometry has in general much lower
spillover than flow cytometry them
essentially fluorochromes however that
doesn't mean that it's non-existent and
there's essentially three primary
sources of the signal interference which
have been described at a few
publications I've got one of them cited
here one the one of the ones is
essentially isotopic impurity so when we
when we have a nice dope like for
example India dye Miam isotope here with
an expected isotopic mass of 145 if that
isotope isn't entirely pure it could be
contaminated with some percentage of 146
for example and that would be one source
of of apparent signal interference or
spillover a second source is oxidation
where any individual isotope can end up
at being coupled with an oxygen
resulting in a sort of a plus sixteen
signal interference the third category
is actually just abundance sensitivity
which reflects the fact that high
detection of an isotope may have a
little bit of section in the India Jason
channels which is relatively minor
compared to the other two sources so
taking all of these points in the
consideration we went ahead and I
assigned isotopes for each of the the
individual anyways on this channel and
then we went ahead and and custom
conjugated all of these in-house using
max power x8 kits from fluid on so once
these antibodies have been conjugated
the next step is validating that the
conjugation is actually been successful
and there's a few ways of doing this but
the our preferred method is to actually
use antibody compete so I'm sure most
people in the audience are probably
familiar with these these are
essentially beads that are coated with
capture antibodies and you can
essentially take these beads mix them
with a given anybody the beads end up
getting coated and then you can run
these on a flow cytometer and these are
often used for performing essentially
generating composition controls by
conventional so cytometry and they're
also quite helpful to use it in mass
cytometry two sort of considerations in
doing this though one is that in mass
cytometry now we don't have traditional
forward side scatter measurement and so
these beads in the absence of that
antibody are essentially invisible to
the instrument they don't have any sort
of native signal on them and that can
create some complications in terms of
detection of the beads so it's helpful
to have some way of labeling the beads
to ensure that they are detectable one
of the ways that the terms that you can
do this is just to incubate these with
the Iridium intercalators that we use
for conventional math cytometry cell
detection and while these intercalators
are supposed to bind to nucleic acid
they do seem to have sufficient you know
nonspecific binding to these beads that
you can see that kind of blue population
there that has sort of enough IR signal
to be to be detectable a second
consideration here is what leads to use
so traditionally when in most of our
workflows you were using the ultra cop
beads developed by a biosigns but the
the RIA antibodies in particular
presumably because of their their
mutated human FC region don't actually
bind to those beads so for this
particular panel we were largely using
the Max kibriya beads from melt any and
I should also note there's a relevant
reference here from Lisa paczynski
at a hundred mice group who've shown a
similar workflow using osmium to label
these beads which is another way of
facilitating their detection bye bye
Massa Tom tree
so having generally lead you can see
that they work very well for being able
to QC that the beat of anybody's
actually been conjugated specifically to
the isotope we we hope it has been
conjugated to so you can see the c19
here is giving us a nice clean signal in
1:42 as expected based on the metal it
was conjugated to and likewise for c6 PC
14 338 another useful aspect of this as
I touched on a few slides back is that
Massa Tom Crean does suffer from from
certain aspects of signal spillover and
these B's offer nicely being able to
visualize that so here you can see
another example of the 145 new DM which
is the primary channel but you can see
that there is detection also of the
signal of that CD for 145 anybody in the
146 channel and that reflects the 3.9%
known isotopic impurity of 146 in the
145 Neil Diamond similarly we can see
that oxide at the plus 16 161 mass then
in this case was calculate to be about
1.5% and if we do this for the for the
entire panel it actually helps to
recapitulate this sort of spillover
chart which many uses am a cytometry me
have been familiar with already where
you can see that for every anybody we
can detect the relative amount of
spillover in any of the channels due to
either oxidation or or isotopic impurity
and a method that's recently been
developed is essentially use this to
actually compensate site off data to be
able to correct for this so head nearly
this is something I don't spend too much
effort doing partly because we don't
find the compensation really helps to
correct for the underlying issues of of
mass spreading or sort of signal
dilution of a single resolution but
based on expansion of the negative
populations with compensation
all right so that's essentially the
first step of validating these
antibodies with beads to ensure that
we've we've conjugated the correct mass
we're seeing signal where we expect to
see them the next step then is to do a
second on a validation with actual
biological samples and validation and
titration so here we tend to use sort of
a three-step approach we start off with
the antibodies that are three four
canonical subsets that show kind of very
clear bimodal distributions and these
can typically be titrated in the absence
of any sort of cellular contact so
simply type trading cd3 on an otherwise
on stain samples still allows you to
resolve your CVC positive and negative
populations fairly well and determine
what is an optimal concentration to do
stain at and I should note with mass
spectrometry were often not using fully
saturating concentrations of these
antibodies instead we're looking for
optimal separation of a positive and
negative population and one of the
metrics we use for this is the average
overlap frequency which is a method we
published a couple of years ago that
essentially calculates how much
separation you have between a defined
positive and define negative and we try
and maximize this metric with our with
our titrations so the second set of
citations is antibodies for which some
cellular context is helpful so for
example when ty doing anybody like cd25
it's helpful to be able to specifically
gate on cd4 t-cells as you can see here
and then within those cd4 t-cells we can
now evaluate cd25 and CD 127 and find
the concentrations allows us to resolve
that T right population and again in the
absence of having the cellular context
if we were just to be titrating cd25 on
the both population it's more difficult
to evaluate what is a known positive and
no negative for this sort of exercise
and similarly here's another example of
CX 0 5 and cd45 RA below
so these this is also actually useful
for antibodies wear that are sort of
expressed in a heterogeneous format so
one example here is CD 16 this is being
titrate in cold blood and you can see
that B cells here are serving as our
negative control neutrophils are serving
as our positive control and sort of
eyeballing this with neutrophils it
looks like we're getting you know close
to saturation there's anybody at about
0.5 nanograms per microliter of whole
blood
however cv 16 is also expressed by other
cell types in blood and so by being able
to define that cell for context we can
actually see now that even though 0.5 or
even 0.25 nanograms per microliter is
sufficient to resolve our cd16 positive
neutrophils it looks like we need much
higher concentrations to be able to
resolve our cd16 high NK cells and our
CT 16 high monocytes
so in other context were titrating in
anybody with sort of known cell or
contacts is helpful in trimmin optimal
concentrations
and then the third and final category of
anybody's are those that are essentially
dynamic activation markers and may not
be expressed at sufficiently high
expression levels in sort of a normal
healthy donor sample so example here is
PDL one we're using sort of cd8 t-cells
as a negative control cd14 monocytes as
a positive population will be
potentially expect to see some
expression and we can see in general
there's relatively low expression here
it does seem like we're getting a
dose-dependent increase in PDL one
expression on monocytes but when we look
at our cd8 t-cells which we expect to be
predominantly negative for PDL one we
can see a similar dose depend
increasingly this is largely an increase
in background and so based on this one
might conclude that our PDL conjugation
is PDL one conjugation has failed you
know we don't get an effective detection
but of course the alternative is that we
simply aren't seeing sufficient
expression of this and so now we can
repeat this experiment but now using
whole blood spiked with some 48-hour Phe
stimulated PBMCs where the interferon is
expected to drive up regulation of PDL
one and now using this sample we can
kind of get on both the the healthy bill
blood sample as well as those those
PBMCs that have been spiked into it and
we can see that again once while we
don't see much expression the healthy
old blood we can see very robust
expression on those pH a stimulated mono
site so we know that anybody's working
we know a conjugation succeeded this
just tells us that the physiological
dynamic range of this in a healthy blood
sample is too low or below the level of
detection but hopefully in a perturbed
setting expression might increase to the
point that we can in fact resolve this
so once we sort of validated each of
these antibodies individually and in
sort of their appropriate context we can
then go ahead and test the entire
antibody panel to confirm that all the
antibodies are being expressed sort of
on populations that we expect them to
and to see how they those populations
may resolve so I'm just using a tease me
analysis here I ran inside a bank and
we're showing you representative data
from twelve of the markers in the in the
panel
some of the kind of key canonical ones
and again just there's several more
anybody's here but broadly speaking you
can see that sort of you have this large
population of neutrophils in the center
characterized by C 16 C 16 there's some
use and it fills on the side there 16 16
negative and so on and so forth and
another way to be able to evaluate this
sort of data is to actually perform some
clustering and one way in which we do
this is to actually use flow some
clustering and cluster annotation using
the Australia Diagnostics platform and
so here you can see on the left that
there's a heat map where every column
corresponds to one of the markers in our
panel every row is a cluster defined by
expression patterns across those it's a
little bit hard to read the text there
and we can also go and take those
clusters and actually map them back onto
our TC plot and kind of further confirm
how how all of these relate to each
other I'm not going to belabor this
essentially a deeper dive into this
suggests that all of the antibodies in
our panel are in fact being expressed on
the cell types we would hope they would
and they're providing sort of
interesting resolution of that
pathological hydrogen ad
um so having sort of optimized this
panel our next step was he wanted to
confirm how much blood we actually need
to be able to perform the study I
mention at the start this is a study
with with pediatric and neonatal samples
we really want to be able to use as
little blood as possible and so we
essentially titrated down these
antibodies with given blood volumes and
and we're able to see that these four
major populations what is the lowest
concentration or lowest volume of blood
at which we're able to see sort of
stable frequencies of these and we from
this analysis ultimately concluded the
200 250 microliters is sufficient for
resolution of most circulating the mean
populations there's obviously greater
hydrogen aiding some of the very rare DC
subsets and things of that sort but it
seemed like it would be doable in the
context of this particular study
so the last aspect I want watching hears
and actually go about implementing this
famil in the setting of kind of a
multi-site sample collection with these
minimal samples I touched on before so
one way in which we we often deploy site
officer to do sort of a standard blood
collection we isolate PBMCs we
cryopreserve PBMCs and then when ready
for analysis we sell those samples and
batches and we perform our staining so
this is kind of a fairly effective
workflow the primary downsides are that
it's quite labor-intensive because it
does require that PBMC isolation which
also requires relatively larger blood
volumes for effective isolation as well
as cryopreservation and storage and it
can also be somewhat Pro to technical
artifacts though being able to batch
samples for analysis does help to
mitigate that to some extent
but in this case that really isn't
feasible partly because of the blood
volumes are dealing with a second
approach is to simply use whole blood
monitoring and to essentially collect
blood ship that blood to a central lab
and perform real-time skating in
acquisition so this is labor-intensive
largely because it requires that
real-time staining and processing so if
it does if one needs to assemble this
panel on a regular basis that's also
somewhat error-prone and prone to
technical batch effects and then one of
the challenges also with collecting
blood at multiple sites and shipping
them to a central site for analysis is
that you have to have very strict limits
on the time points because obviously as
blood is sitting in a tube you would
expect there going to be some teeny tip
akane - so these populations it might be
happening spontaneously that are going
to provide technical impacts on ultimate
data quality so this is the same optimal
either in our workflow
so third option is to collect that blood
and to stabilize it at the site of
collection and one one buffer that we
use routinely for this is the smart to
buffer which is an effective way of
being able to fix stabilize and
ultimately cryopreserve blood and thus
acquire preserved blood given me that's
now essentially frozen can be shipped to
a central lab for for batch staining so
the advantage of this is it's a very
efficient workflow because stabilizing
blood is is much easier than staining
blood that's essentially just the
addition of a single buffer to a tube
and then shifting that tube to a few
freezer a downside though is that
because fixation is involved there are
certain epitopes that are going to be
impacted by this I'm showing two
examples here so you can see that CRT h2
which stains basophils very effectively
in whole blood that's stating is
completely lost
looking in that smart tube fixed whole
blood another example here is extr three
cubic receptor where you can see that we
have sort of a different problem where
you know in the in the whole blood we
can see kind of that nice resolution of
6:03 positive versus negative cd4 T
cells monocytes are predominately
negative but in this market fixed whole
blood we sort of lose that positive
discrimination on the on the cd4 T cells
and we gain this nonspecific and a
background staining on the on the cd14
web site so certain marker distributions
are definitely affected by fixation and
if you're curious it's but this wasn't
done with with the RIA antibodies but we
did recently publish a comprehensive
screening of 300-plus antibodies that we
evaluated for fixation compatibility
using sort of similar methods sort of
shown here
so the challenge there with option three
is that it's efficient workflow but it's
not compatible with all the markers in
the panel ultimately our preferred
workflow is really to collect the blood
perform real-time staining on site so
the blood essentially stay in fresh and
then in the sixth and stabilize using
the smart T buffer and then ship to our
central lab for ultimate data
acquisition but nor for this workflow to
work the real-time staining has to be as
sort of easy and simple as possible to
be done at these these sort of remote
clinics that don't have much experience
with Massa Tom tree or any sort of sort
of biospecimen processing and so we
accomplish this with Elias allies our
entire panel and to dispense this panel
and single-use cryo vials so what this
essentially looks like is we have these
cryo vials that have a little live fear
of anybody in the vial I should mention
we did this commercially with a company
called violife and so what can be done
at the clinic is that we simply take 200
microliters the whole blood we add it to
the anybody live sphere we incubate that
for 20 minutes and then we add our Smart
TV stabilization buffer and transfer
this tube to the freezer and then those
frozen samples are shipped to our
central lab for the for the final and
DNA intercalation
as well as data acquisition on the
instrument
and just to show you that this workflow
seems to work quite well so I'm showing
you up top the same panel and it's
liquid versus lyophilized form and
here's just a range of antibodies and
you can see that generally speaking
we're seeing very good preservation of
these dating profiles and in both liquid
as well as the lifelike antibody because
some kind of some primary canonical I
mean saving markers we're seeing the
same thing here for some of the
chemokine receptors in the panel that
showed these get a slightly more subtle
expression patterns all of which seem to
be preserved quite well another way to
evaluate this would be for the entire
panel or rather another advantage of the
live flies panel beyond simply looking
comparable to the liquid panel is that
we expect this does provide enhance
stability of our panel over long periods
of time
and one way to evaluate this is to do an
accelerated stress test at elevated
temperatures so you can see up top we
have our life lights panel and it's
being either staying fresh or it's been
stored at 45 degree Celsius for up to
eight weeks and you can see that for
that entire eight week period we're
getting broad preservation of the the
antibody staining profiles that we get
despite stressing this panel to a pretty
significant extent and if you contrast
that with a conventional liquid panel at
the bottom you can see that even a
single week at 45 degrees
pretty much means that most of the
animals in the panel are toast which is
not entirely surprising another way of
evaluating that is using that average
overlap frequency metric I mentioned
earlier you can kind of see in the
little heat map there that that single
week is really compromised expression
but most of the markers in the panel
were as it's being preserved quite well
in the case of the live flies panel and
so this gives us confidence that we can
actually ship these things out to people
you know that mean temperature they can
sit in the clinic for however long is
needed to be able to perform the
staining and then we can expect to get
you know fairly robust data back to us
to also evaluate this workflow actually
works we did a bunch of testing just to
show that the staining replica blood
samples but these panels is reproducible
so here's one example from one donor
where we have three replicas a loquats
of 200 microliters of blood from the
same tube that have been staying
separately with independent cryo vials
and broadly characterizing some of the
major marine populations here and you
can see that our since our frequencies
of these subsets are highly reproducible
over time and the TCE plots
show you the general standing expression
is also highly reproducible across these
these Alec Watson calculating this
across five donors we find that our CVS
are typically less than 5% for for all
defied immune subsets so this is this is
purely technical reproducibility another
important consideration is all true sort
of biological stability of these
populations so this is a similar
experiment but here instead of taking
replicate Alec Watts from the same TV
blood we had the same donors come back
at two week or at one week intervals and
so we have a blood draw a zero they
seven and a 14 and and similarly again
you can see our broad expression
profiles look quite similar but we do
see more variability here in the
frequencies of some of these subsets so
for example the monocytes you can see
there are elevated at day 14 roll20 and
this makes sense but it does tell us
that there is going to be some expected
it's normal biological variability in
some of these populations and this helps
us set kind of thresholds that we would
expect to want to look for changes
beyond in the case of our our cohort so
essentially we might be able to conclude
from this that a 3 percent change and
monocyte frequency might just be part of
normal biological variation whereas
perhaps a change of you know 20 percent
is going to exceed that normal
biological variation and reflect
something interesting that might be
happening in that cohort
all right so based on all the validation
data we were fairly confident we could
take this workflow and now deploy it in
the setting of our clinical trial and
that's what happened currently so we
have our our various sites all of which
have been have been shipped these
anybody live spheres and the goal here
is now to can implement this workflow at
various time points along that 12 months
window of the first year of life and
eventual assemblers going to be
aggregated shipped back to us and we're
going to perform message on tree on that
so hopefully in a couple of years I'll
be able to give you some updates on that
so conclude that I've watched you
through some of the the key steps at
each of the some the key considerations
in developing and deploying a study of a
sort
starting from sort of the target
selection the identification of clones
conjugating with antibodies and
validating and titrating them and
ultimately then valve ly applies in that
panel and sort of revalidate in the ly
applies panel and then you know
essentially these these panels have been
distributed to our clinical sites that
real-time whole blood staining is
happening currently and ultimately those
samples are also going to be analyzed to
identify parlance with pediatric allergy
all right I'm going to end there by
acknowledging the entire HIC team in
particular the the site of team of Brian
Bhaskar Jeff and Daniel and our
collaborators Cecilia Barron and should
I gosh we've been running a lot of the
the allergy specific validations around
this I also want to note that we're
always hiring so if this sounds
interesting to you let me know
Thank You Mona and ID'd for your
presentations a quick reminder for our
audience on how to submit questions
simply type them into the drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window labeled ask a
question and click on the send button
our speakers speakers will answer as
many questions as time permits okay the
first question is are there any
downsides to antibody panel
lyophilization
sure I guess the the primary I guess
there's two primary downsides one is
cost so it isn't it isn't cheap at least
a life allows these things commercially
it does scale very well with volume so
this wouldn't really make sense to do in
a study where you only have sort of 50
or so anybody's you 2 or 50 or so vials
you need two lawful eyes but when doing
sort of several hundred or thousands of
tests this does become fairly more cost
effective the other downside is that not
all antibodies do tolerate lawful
ization so I think we we did get lucky
in the context of this panel that
everything seemed to work out quite well
but we have had prior panels where at
least one or two anybody's in the panel
have not tolerated awful ization need to
be spiked him so that is a that is a
potential uh potential concern so I
think the the key is to perform
sufficient validation of the panel pre
and post validation to be confident that
that it's working well
once the panel has been lawful eyes then
I think things are things are pretty
good the one other caveat there is that
there is a tendency for some of these
life as anybody to form from anybody
aggregates this kind of manifest is kind
of a diagonal streak in mass atomic read
data filtering the panel through a point
one micron filter which is kind of our
standard workflow foresight off panels
in general does a very effective job of
mitigating this in the context of this
particular study just because the whole
blood is being added directly to the
tube we expected this is likely going to
be an issue but it can generally be
taken care of the data analysis step
great thank you all right your next
question is are there other ways to
store antibody panels for example
freezing absolutely yeah so this is a
nice technique that was published again
by Hendrik Mies group essentially taking
an antibody panel and sticking it at
minus 80 degrees does a very effective
job of preserving many of these
antibodies for long term stores I should
note that conventional for degree
storage does not work well for foremast
um tree panels we see all sorts of
strange artifacts that happen with a
panel sets around but freezing it does
seem to be quite effective and I think
is a more accessible workflow for many
labs that don't want to embark on lawful
ization I should note the one
disadvantage of that is that shipping
frozen panels and using them in a
multi-site setting is obviously much
more complicated so for this particular
workflow I don't invest as effective but
certainly for single side studies where
samples are simply being stained log
doodly over time frozen panels are an
effective strategy I think
thank you why don't you offer antibodies
directly coupled to isotopes
and so yeah this is pretty simple and
this is just because we don't own the
technology so we also don't have
instruments to test anybody said would
be directly copied to isotopes and that
because so many customers always asked
for the antibodies via our custom
anybody design service we decided to
make an off-the-shelf portfolio out of
it so to offer the pure antibodies but
we cannot offer them capital isotope
thank you it looks like we have time for
one more question what is the minimum
amount to order an antibody via your
custom service so usually our custom
service you have to order at least 500
micrograms because yes just amount where
for us it makes sense to produce it for
the customer but foresight off we
decided to go with 200 micrograms
because we know that the conjugation
kids are usually made for 100 micrograms
and 200 microgram is the minimum we can
afford for the customer so this is yeah
kind of a service for the side of users
so this is only possible if it's
requested for the first side of antibody
not for the other antibodies
thank you I would like to once again
thank Mona and Aidid for their
presentation do you have any final
comments for our audience
I'm for me
no just thank you I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions we would
like to thank our sponsor Milton E
biotech for underwriting today's
educational webcast laberd's will alert
you via email when it's available for
replay we encourage you to share that
you know with your colleagues who may
have missed today's event until next
time goodbye